generally a little bit quieter and then
february and march would be quite recent
we think about 1.2 million pastors
in uh january and with the renewed
covert restrictions through february and
march we think those two months will
fall to about half a million passengers
each month
so what's your best guess now on when
things start to return to normal
is it picking a number out of thin air i
think i think you know
if you take our we take comfort from the
uk vaccination program it looks like
they'll have 50
of the uk population vaccinated by the
end of march that's almost all of the
high high-risk groups
and therefore we think europe will be
catching up i think through april may
and june
we think by the end of june there will
be a reasonable return to
short-haul travel both uk domestic and
intra-european
and i think that's enough for us to see
families returning to the beaches of
europe during the summer in june july
august and september
and that will start the post covered
recovery on the back of a successful
vaccine program
how problematic would it be for you if
europe mainland europe didn't achieve
vaccination levels in line with the uk
relatively quickly
i i think it would be problematic but
you know i think there's going to be
such political pressure on them
i think they will throw money at it now
to catch up with the uk
during march april or during a march
april and may
uh the production issues will have
resolved themselves i think you'll see
the johnson and johnson vaccine will
have been licensed
you have many more vaccines licensed and
therefore the production
shortfalls that are hampering the
european rollout through january and
february would have been eliminated
how unhelpful are these latest
restrictions from the uk government or
does it really not make much difference
doesn't make much difference you know i
mean the restriction we the restrictions
once they brought in
you know 72-hour pcr testing frankly
we've canceled most of our flights
so most of the other airlines there's
essentially nobody flying now
you know hotel quarantines are
ineffective but they don't matter
because nobody's flying
uh and i think all of our focus now the
focus of the entire economy in britain
will be on
the successful vaccine rollout program
and i think the government deserve
credit for those successes
i'm very critical of them when they fail
as they did through most of the
cloven pandemic but there's no doubt
that the uk have
delivered the world's most successful
vaccine program
and we would like to see europe copy
that success and catch up
so you're relatively optimistic that the
market will come back to life this
summer are you seeing that in
advanced bookings right now i think it
will come back even stronger
and for two reasons yeah i think i've
come back stronger for two reasons
firstly there's going to be a huge
amount of capacity that's been taken out
of the system in the uk we've seen the
failure of flybe thomas coke
air berlin in germany and secondly
ryanair has taken ordered another 200
aircraft from boeing we start taking
those new aircraft deliveries this
summer
which will give us more aircraft more
new capacity
and there is huge pent-up demand i think
families all over britain all over
europe who've been at home homeschooling
for the last
couple of months are desperate to go on
holidays they're desperate to go back to
the beaches of spain portugal italy
greece
and i see you we'll see that return
quite strongly once we get to the school
holidays in june and july this year
but are you seeing it in forward
bookings just yet
we're singing in forward boogies yet
into the june july
august period four bookies are
noticeably stronger
uh since we started running the the chap
and go advertising campaign over
christmas
uh april may very quiet easter is a
write-off
but very strong bookings into the peak
summer period
now you touched on the new aircraft
dollars from boeing then this is the
first chance we've had to speak to you
since then was there any hesitation in
your mind you've ordered 75
new 737 max game changers as you call
them
no there was no hesitation you know we
have to be fair we've been negotiating
with boeing compensation for the delayed
delivery of the aircraft
we've also negotiated modest price
reductions
in return for increasing the size of the
order you know these will be among the
lowest
cost boeing aircraft we've ever taken
delivery of uh they are
offer us four percent more seats but
they burn 16 less fuel which will give
us dramatically lower operating costs
going forward
and the good news it means we'll be
returning to flying around here with
even lower fares
for customers for their families and
getting people back moving and more
importantly
getting the british tourism and
hospitality sector back moving again
there's a lot of speculation in the
market at the time that you negotiated a
50 percent discount with boeing any
truth in that
the market is always you know in the
market there's always lots of
speculation we never comment on the
rumor or speculation we're very happy
with the pricing revised pricing we
agree with boeing boeing are happy with
the revised pricing
and i think you know it's enough to say
that these are going to dramatically
lower ryanair's operating costs for the
next five years
into a post-covered recovery and which
are the first routes on which they'll
fly
i think you'll see them first line from
our main bases in dublin in san said
you know today we've announced we've
extended our low-cost growth deal with
sansa by four years out to 2028
so i think stanston will be the first
airport here we'll see the new aircraft
and where customers will enjoy flying on
these new aircraft
and you've said in the statement today
you had three and a half billion euros
worth of cash on the balance sheet at
the end of the quarter
absolutely no plans for any further
capital raising just now
i don't think so most of our focusing is
on we're going to repay the government
uk government 600 million loan in march
we have a bond repayment in june we've
no requirement for any additional
financing or funding
although we have access to those markets
so we could borrow more money at i think
rates of one one and a half percent
at the moment if we wanted to but we
don't see a need
at this point in time and if the vaccine
rollout continues to be successful then
i think there won't be any need going
forward because we'll see
a very strong recovery in cash flows as
people
surge in their millions to book cheap
flights and holidays for
the summer of 2021.